uh good morning and welcome to this
meeting of the mid suffk District
Council planning committee may I first
remind you of some domestic arrangements
please ensure the microphones are turned
off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave please ensure that your mobile
phones are on silent or switched off and
that your laptops are switched to
silent I would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photog or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
if you are intending to do so please
could you inform the committee
Clark If you hear the fire alarm leave
the building immediately via a fire exit
and make your way to the assembly point
I switch toown football ground follow
the signs directing you to the fire exit
at each end of the floor do not enter
the atrium that's the ground floor area
and the walkways if you are in the
atrium at the time of the alarm follow
the signs to the nearest fire exit use
the stairs not the lifts do not re-enter
the building until told it is safe to do
so so uh before we begin uh there are
some introductions we've got the um
members of the committee on my right uh
they will be um debating and determining
the
applications uh on on my left hand side
um we have um first of all we've got um
one of the case officers Alex Scott and
then we've got uh area planning manager
Gemma Walker um the chief planning
officer I can't remember his job title
um Phil is Bell uh and then we've got um
other case officers who will be doing
the case um uh the second case uh we
have some Ward members uh councelor John
Whitehead and councelor Andrew Stringer
who will be speaking on their cases um
and just um later on during the um uh
morning proceeding we are expecting some
visitors who are visiting the County
Council today from Project 21 I
understand there's likely to be about 10
or so of them um they will probably be
coming in um to uh watch our second case
um they're visiting us because uh
they're visiting the count County
Council today and we are the meeting
that's happening in the council chamber
um so we may have to have a slight break
while they um sort themselves out so um
if I could then move to the oh and I've
also got my um government's officers uh
CLA Philpot Mandy Smith and Beth Webb
who'll make sure that everything is um
in order and we've got the legal advisor
in
deay uh so can I move to the agenda uh
do we have any apologies for absence and
substitution n ree chair thank you
number two uh receive Declarations of
discl disclosable pecuniary interests
and other registerable or non-reg
interests by members are there any to
declare
no is you can recognize Council Penny
I'll if I he can add to what I'm about
to say if it's necessary um councelor
Penny as as you know is one is not a
regular member of this committee um he
is one of the two Ward members he took
my advice yesterday I've spoken to the
acting monitoring officer so when we're
agreed on this situation that um
councelor peny um I think I'm going to
start calling in Mr Penny because that's
what he is in this meeting Mr penny is
an objector to the the hemingstone item
the second item and if if he was here as
a member of the committee he would be
obliged to declare a disclosable
pecuniary interest because he's an
objector that that isn't that doesn't
automatically lead to you having
peculiar interest but he is a
neighboring land owner whose property
might be affected by the success or
failure of the application if that if he
were here as a member he the Lord would
require him not to be not not to speak
or vote will be in the room at all but I
and the monitoring officer have agreed
that because he's not here as a member
of the committee he's not exercising the
he's sensibly leaving the role of Lord
Ward member to councelor Whitehead who's
here today but it it is acceptable for
him to speak as an
objector as long as he leaves the room
as soon as the public speaking is
finished and we go into debate and
that's that's what we we will do today
and I'll I'll speak to the Clark about
how we put that in the minutes thank you
thank you Mr
Penny um uh item number three
Declarations of lobbying um have any any
Declarations of lobbying to declare no
uh number four Declarations of personal
site visits are there any to
declare no uh number five uh
confirmation of the minutes of the
planning committee meeting MPL
2316 which was held on the 11th of
October 2023 are there any points
regarding the accuracy of the
minutes no um could I have a proposer
thank you Council Hingham uh and a
second uh councelor Davis um so the
governance officer will now conduct the
electronic vote and Council Lawrence
will have to do his
manually thank you chair members that
vote is in progress on your apps
councilor
Lawrence well thank
you
councelor waros are you having trouble
with the
app do do you want to do it manually or
have you just done it
it thank you members chair that's seven
votes for and one abstention that's
carried uh thank you so the minutes of
the meeting have been confirmed and will
be signed in due course um so we now
move to item number six uh to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme non
received chair thank you uh right so
item number seven is the schedule of
planning applications uh we will stick
to the order um
uh of the agenda so we will go straight
to DC
23305 land adjacent to 17 brockford Road
mosam um and I will invite the case
officer Alex Scott to introduce the
application to the committee thank you
Alex uh thank you chairman um as members
this is uh item 7A in the agenda
application DC
23305 land AJ to 17 brockford Road in
melam and the application seeks full
planning permission for the change of
use of land for grazing of horses and
erection of stables with new vehicular
access now there are several items in
the uh in the late papers uh which I'd
like to draw your attention to please uh
now the application has been called to
committee at the request of the uh Ward
member councilor
Stringer and the Callin form is attached
um with reference to to uh a prior
planning appeal um on part of the site
for eight dwellings uh which is also
attached in the late uh sorry table
papers um along with the relevant red
and blue site location plan for that uh
particular case and
application and as summarized um there
are concerns uh from the Ward member
with regards to harm to the historic
setting of the site uh the erosion of
Highway Safety
and conflict with neighboring plan polic
neighborhood plan policy
mp10 uh which relates to open spaces and
to principal views uh which I've uh
provided at slide 10 of the presentation
and the site um is also uh visually
important open space and uh local plan
policy s sp3 of the 1998 plan is
therefore also relevant and referred to
in my report uh now we have had a very
late uh
representation received from your
heritage officers in terms of an update
of their position um this was received
um at 20 5 uh yesterday
afternoon and uh I believe we have
copies uh which have been or can be
circulated I think they need to be
circulated okay um so we could just um
allow the government's officer to
distribute them
yeah and should should we also I think
we need to perhaps have a break to allow
members to read it um so um if you just
if that's all right Alex we just stop
here in in mid flow there and let let
everyone read the
paper
right has everyone um have you all had
time to read the late paper uh thank you
we go back to you then Alex thank you
uh thank you chairman so just to
summarize for anybody uh listening in
who hasn't had the benefit of um of
reading that um so it's a view of um uh
your heritage officers members that uh
the site is historically R has a
historically rural setting of uh melam
and makes a contribution uh to the
character and appearance of the
conservation area and the significance
of the grade one listed uh Church of St
Mary's um the the site is split by
modern development um including uh two
new dwellings which are currently into
uh construction and have uh extent
planning
permission and um this has now left a
rather constrained uh narrow Gap within
the uh Street Scene Frontage uh when
compared to
historically so it's your heritage
officers view that the contribution to
the significant significance of Heritage
assets is now more
limited um in the location where the
stable building is
proposed your heritage officers uh raise
no objection to the general design and
character of the building itself um but
note that this would close off the
remaining connection between the assets
and their rural
surrounds uh your heritage officer's
view is that um harm is
increased uh by the extent of the
building and Associated parking and hard
standing and they have identified a very
low level of less than substantial harm
to the uh setting and significance of
the Heritage
assets um and that is due to the uh now
limited um importance of the
area um they've advised um alterations
to the scheme perhaps uh reducing the
size of the building pushing it closer
to the approved dwellings and rotating
through 90° and reducing the extent of
the car parking area and they have um
recommended uh conditions um with
regards materials and Landscaping and
fences in
particular and your heritage officers um
do not consider the change of use of the
remainder of of the site um to result in
any form of harm at all to the setting
significance of Heritage assets and they
consider that still be in keeping uh
broadly with the uh historic use of the
of the site so that's just in brief
summary
there okay so uh moving to the uh
presentation
itself so we have the location of mlam
there within the
district
this is an aerial map of the S site and
surrounding area and the site extends to
approximately 1.4
hectares here we have a constraints map
of uh the site so the site lies outside
of the uh settlement boundary which is
um edged in brown here and I do have a
better plan at the request of a chairman
on the next slide so uh I'll refer to
that in due
course and so uh the site uh comprises
uh an area of grassland um in grade
three
agricultural quality um although it's
not currently in use uh for food uh
production access excuse me um access to
the site does lie within uh environment
agency uh flood zones 2 and three which
you can see
are is here this uh blue hatched
area uh but the remainder of the site is
uh within um environment agency flood
zone one where there is the least
likelihood of flooding
from um from River or tidal
sources as uh referred to uh in your
heritage officer's comments the uh the
proposal site affects the uh setting of
the grade one listed Church which is
here highlighted in green and the church
churchard which extends to approximately
here and there is also a uh a moted area
here which is uh a scheduled ancient
Monument so another Heritage asset which
the uh proposal would affect the setting
of and we have the conservation area
here also a Heritage asset uh
highlighted in in purple hatch uh but
the site does lie outside of that
Conservation Area but does affect the
setting so we move now to uh an excerpt
from the neighborhood plan figure
2.2 uh so you can see the settlement
boundary here edged in black and the
conservation area boundary edged in in
red we also have the public foot path
which crosses the uh
Cemetery here and runs along the North
Boundary of the site adjacent to the
moted site and out here to the uh this
Lane connecting to brookford Road at the
end uh the the site uh is also um as
previously mentioned uh an area of
visually important open space um as
designated in the current 98 uh local
plan uh and effect uh view
10 which is here principal view
10 uh and that's designated in the uh
current neighborhood
plan this is the uh red line site
location plan submitted with the
application uh so the area edged in uh
red is the extent of the uh site and the
area edged in blue um has extand
planning permission for for two
dwellings which I believe uh is
currently under
construction and the blue color also
indicates land in control of the uh of
the
applicant so here we have the uh
proposed block plan uh in the location
of the um the operational development
the uh physical development of the
site uh so the proposed building is um
is set forward of the site um
approximately 4.6 M from the uh fronting
boundary which uh is delineated by this
uh hedge R which is existing and
proposed to be
retained and it's approximately 20 M
from the uh from the corner of the site
here um access is proposed to be by the
existing field access here which um has
approval to be uh upgraded as part of
the development for the two dwellings
which you can see the the nearest
dwelling here currently under
construction um the boundary treatments
throughout the site would um be a mix of
1.2 meter high post and rail fences um
predominantly in this
area and post and wire fences for the
remainder and there's an additional
hedge to the cemetery bandry proposed in
this
location and part of the conditions
where um
looking to secure those by Landscaping
conditions and further information as
well as part of a landscaping scheme um
should you be minded to approve of
course so on the proposed
elevations um so the building would
measure uh
22.3 M long at its maximum
extent um about 4.8 m
in
width and about 4.4 m in maximum height
to the ridge we also have the uh
elevations of the post and rail fence
there approximately 1.2 m in total
height here we have the proposed floor
plan so it would be uh the building
would be split into five uh sections um
with three Stables a hay and bedding
store and a Feed and Tack room with a
covered walkway to the uh Frontage which
would face into the
site so here we have another excerpt
from the neighborhood plan showing the
uh principal views and uh the Key View
as mentioned is uh Key View 10
here so on to some photographs of the
site um these were taken in April of
this year
2023 uh so this first view is from the
corner of brockford Road Church Road and
Oak Farm Lane uh looking up Church
Road we then have a view looking around
the corner of brockford Road um from
outside uh the site opposite the Glee
way
estate um and you can see the uh
existing gated pedestrian access to the
site
here and um I think it's worth pointing
out a similar building that you might be
able to see here um as what's proposed
on the other side of the uh of the
road and uh this is a view up brockford
road from the junction of Oak Farm Lane
and um I think this shows the extent of
the existing hedge row proposed to be uh
retained and in H through a landscaping
scheme and again the similar building on
the opposite side of the road
there and a view uh up Church Road again
given an idea of the existing Frontage
of the
site now this is a view from uh the
interior of the of the site so the
proposed uh building would be
approximately in this location behind
the fronting hedge row and this fenced
area you can see there is uh the site of
the uh approved
dwellings this building over here is an
existing dwelling um further down
brockford
road so this is again from uh inside of
the site so this is the existing uh
bandry with the uh extension to the uh
the cemetery uh Beyond and you just
might be able to um make out the uh
Church Tower in this location and this
boundary is proposed to be hedged as
part of The Proposal proposal
layout and then just turning right from
that previous uh view looking further
into the
site and then again moving closer to the
uh boundary with the approved dwellings
looking back
into the site and you can see there the
uh the church church
Tower and again this is looking at uh
that boundary with the uh proposed
dwellings and the existing
dwelling and then looking
back towards Church Road at the end
there so that concludes the uh
presentation um as set out in the papers
officers recommendation is for approval
subject to the conditions as listed
thank you thank you um do we have any
questions from members uh Council having
them um thanks I've got um two and the
first one is um which is the best um
photo of view1 you'd say sort of street
names but they meant nothing to me can
you just say this is the view that's
talked about on the on the neighborhood
plan and it's this
one was that was that first photo
actually that slide 11 I I thought might
be the actual
view I think that shows
it okay thank you but do you have
another question sorry and um the other
one is um on slide seven it's the it
sort of shows the entrance and
everything but I'm just thinking there's
lots of sort of gateways and what have
you yes thank you this one I'm just
thinking if you were bringing a horse
Lorry in how would that actually work if
you've got you know quite a big vehicle
you
know proposal is to use this uh existing
access um and they
would
[Music]
um that that's been assessed by highways
and that seem to be adequate that's all
I can say may maybe we could ask the um
agent I think is now here we could ask
him about access um is that okay have
you have you right so I think we've got
councelor hardingham and I did I see
councelor War boys as well thank
you thank you chair um yes um do you
have any photos of the site taken from
the public footpath adjacent to the
church I don't I'm afraid and and do you
have any photos of the site in its
present condition in its present
condition um the photos were taken in
April I don't have any more recent
photos I'm afraid um from the foot path
no I have walked that foot path and it
is quite quite enclosed with with growth
at the moment so it's a bit difficult to
see outside um so without actually going
on site I don't uh know what photographs
would uh really show so that's the
reason I haven't taken
any okay uh thank you anything else uh
counselor War
boys yes thank you chair um yeah I I
just need to clear up the um how
significant the history of this site is
in relationship to the current
neighborhood plan which is is quite a
new neighborhood plan which has this as
a uh a visually important open
space um the first application was for
eight buildings which was turned down on
appeal because it was too intr basic
essentially too intrusive the second one
was approved that though the the
inspector did recognize that it
had harm on the visual open space
nevertheless the economic value
outweighed that so the second one was
approved but those decisions all took
place before the neighbor plan was
actually established by
referendum um
so and the question my mind is now
is how much weight if you like we should
attach to that neighborhood plan and
it's
establishing um by referendum the this
visually important space and and the um
as the slide shows the um High
significant
views
um would that tilt things against any
economic um value of of
development um well the the site has
been um allocated if you like as
visually important open space for some
time in fact it dates back to the 1998
plan so um that's you know historic and
you know the inspector would have um in
fact did I was part of that appeal but
uh they took that into account um when
they were considering the excuse me the
uh the two applications you refer
to um
now yeah the uh the neighborhood plan is
now adopted part of the development plan
so in terms of the weight we should be
attaching to that um it's part of a
development plan so yes full weight and
um yeah with uh with mp10 that policy
and the principal
views we should have do consideration
for I would say so they now carry
significant weight oh absolutely yes
yeah full or full weight I'm not sure
how but um Mr isbel would you like to
inter chairman just just for clarity I
mean you're supposed to make decisions
in accordance with the development plan
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise the national policy framework
indicates that economic um benefits
can't quite remember the precise terming
but the that economic benefits do carry
significant weight but the primary
consideration in any planning decision
should be the development plan that's
the statutary duty thank you
okay um any further questions from
members uh councelor
maton a look at the best um slide that
shows us um that illustrates the points
that the the the Heritage officers are
making um so I think it' been useful to
actually
seen what he was talking about um right
is
that whichever
okay so just just the the key Point
again then the the church is is to the
left
there and so that's that's the that's
the asset that's
referenced um there there are three
actually there's the uh the church which
is grade one listed you then have this
moted site which is a scheduled ancient
monument and you have the conservation
area as well so those are the three
principle Heritage assets we're talking
about I see and so and then the the the
houses that have
eroded the the the the situation on that
right hand
corner outside the um yes oh I see they
right
yes and so and then the
view the view is is
from that
corner
okay well that that helps one to
understand it
so okay that's that's the one question
thank you yeah the other one um being
entirely unfamiliar with with um keeping
horses um it's quite a big stable
building in fact the Heritage officer
comments on that um three horses
um do do we have any understanding of of
where the three es and and
1.4 hectares is is sort of re
realistic um will the horses be
overcrowded on on such a small piece of
land or over Grace or over something I'm
afraid I don't have that information
perhaps but I definitely don't no no
indeed um yeah perhaps a a question for
the applicants agent who Wasing suggest
councilor
thank you chair um would it be possible
to see I think it was slide 16 which had
the the view to the um Cemetery from the
field I've got the right
one so at the moment there's no barrier
between the end of the cemetery and the
field no visual barrier it's just no
visual barrier I would
say here at the moment but that is
proposed to be a hedge as part of the
Landscaping scheme so that will change
yeah um thank you and the other question
is it okay to have another question um
was about the um the Heritage officer
had
proposed potentially reorienting the
stable
block um and I
just hadn't quite got my head around
what they were
suggesting um uh yeah it's a bit
difficult to
um really understand what um their
intentions are but um I
presume they thought it was better to
move it uh further towards the uh the
dwelling here although I'm not sure what
that would do to turning and
parking um we'd have to check that with
uh our highways colleagues as well and
then rotating the building through 90
degrees so the longest axis would be
adjacent to this
neighboring boundary
here I believe that's what they were but
but we we're only determining what we've
got in front of us really so um uh
councelor
Davis uh sorry chair the previous
councelor asked a question I was going
to raise so um well if there are no
further questions from the rest of you I
I've got a couple of questions um one of
the photos showed a pedestrian access
which I believe is shown on that plan
you've got on slide seven but it almost
looks like it's covered with hedge um
and and is that is to stay and to serve
what purpose because it's right on the
bend that's my first
question uh no correct chairman that is
shown to be
um yes hedged off I suppose from that
plan um it says on that plan pedestrian
access to to remain I think it's really
small print but um I think that's what
it says and it just presumably that's
just a private access into that extra
bit of field that's all it is yeah it is
a private access it's not a public right
of way I can confirm that certainly okay
and my my second question is is I sort
of thought about when councilor warboys
was talking about the mlam neighborhood
plan because of course mam neighborhood
plan was the first neighborhood plan um
in mids suffk um and it's been renewed
in 2022 I believe or or refreshed
so um with regard to the history of the
site and the fact that there were
numerous planning applications first for
two and then they tried to make it eight
were those initial applications for the
first two was that before or after the
first neighborhood mention neighborhood
plan and what has changed about this
particular area in the latest version of
the plan because it's it's been renewed
in 22 so presumably there are some
changes so have there been significant
changes to this area of
mlam I believe the update was um the
addition primarily of
um housing allocations I believe that
was the that was the main um update
there were some obviously updates to the
wording the policy but the views and the
visually important open space and all
that all that part of the neighborhood
plan is the same as it was when it was I
don't I can't remember what date it was
first adopted but are they the same as
they were when those houses first got
the applicate got got
permission um that that that is my
recollection I would have to does Gemma
want to pop well I just wonder maybe the
parish council might um come back just
perhaps as a question for them so I'm
sure they'll have a lot more information
and they can share with us thank you
okay so if there are no further
questions from um
uh what page am I on uh lost the page
right um right so we've got um we've had
questions uh I will now invite the
public speakers to address the committee
um and I think first on my list we have
Mr Paul Allen from Menan Parish Council
so if you would like to um press the
button on your microphone and um I have
my Hightech timer you have three minutes
to make your representation thank you
and
welcome thank you thank you for hearing
me
um I've got a report from the parish
council but firstly I'd like to address
the flooding
issue and um
historically this
may be
correct but in view of the last two
flooding incidents which occurred two
weeks
apart that L land appeared to be
flooded which is beyond the um flood
plane and seriously flooded but I only
saw it from the photographs of the
entrance to the dwellings so I couldn't
see I can't see what HP what happened in
the field but there have been various
land Works done which appear to me to
have reduced the level of that
field
um the the local plan
um certainly says that we object to
it the historic environment will be
changed slightly because of the height
of the um the height of the stable and
even if as suggested it might have might
move that would have to be looked at in
situe when that proposal is
made
um the historic environment I don't have
anything to add um but the
this from the site which was allowed
there have been several um uh extra and
it's what I call Salami slicing of
changing the actual planning
consent um to suit the um the
owners um
[Music]
and
the the size of the stable we don't
quite understand why for the two horses
that we were two aged horses that we
were originally going uh to expect to to
use that field um why there are three
Stables now required and the size of the
Stables appear to be a little larger
than um my might be another case and if
these horses are that old um how long
will it how long will it be before um
they die um and in that circumstance is
What will what will happen to the
established stable block once it's once
it's
there
um the the last thing is is a a request
that you do give wait to our planning uh
to our neighborhood plan because we've
got
three uh two outstanding ones one of
which has been
approved um which was um agreed by the
previous chair um if you could if you
could finish um yeah I will your final
sentence please yeah agreed by the
previous chair that it was was out
outside the um outside the neighborhood
plan and the current one which is not
yet approved um will add I think 68
houses on a hill which will lead into
the in directly into the flood
plane thank you thank you thank you uh
do we have any questions of the parish
council
representative
councel thank you um I was just you
mentioned the flooding I was going to
ask about that um did was the road
access blocked um with the recent
flooding Village was locked in uh over
overnight and that particular Corner um
I believe was about 4 feet plus
deep as were most of the as were most of
the accessible roads to mandalam it was
it was really really bad so in terms of
somebody who maybe was trying to get
through to check on animals it would
have been imposs well I do know one on
the opposite side of the road who had
some difficulty moving her horses to a
spare piece of ground uh behind moat
Farm which is listed uh sorry which is
noted on the on the uh information we be
give thank you any further questions uh
Council m
thank you yeah I think for the officers
really um I suspect and can you confirm
that the um the identity of the horses
is rather like the identity of the
applicant that it's not a material
consideration do you just want to
confirm that yeah this is one of the
things if they didn't have horses we
couldn't even consider that it's for a
stables it can only be used for horses
under the current consent that's what we
need to consider so yes even if horses
are
or any horses yes there's nothing
stopping somebody buying or purchasing
them in the
future councelor War
boys I think it's just something that's
come up from uh the the chair of the
parish council whether he can answer it
or not um The Heritage officer describes
a domestic stable out
building um does that differ to an
agricultural building in the same sense
that uh you could have development
rights on an agricultural building but a
domestic stable out building might not
have the same development
rights yes so a horse is not necessarily
Agriculture and in this case we're
looking out to use of land for keeping
of horses and stabling for them so it's
not agricultural there wouldn't be
agricultural PD rights and there also
wouldn't be residential PD rights is not
a house so that neither of those PD
rights then come in relation to the
state
it's just the stables for horses and the
use of land for keeping of
horses thank you for clarifying um any
more
questions okay so um we don't have an
objector or a supporter uh but we do
have the agent uh Mr Ben Elvin so um
over to you thank you uh you can have
your three
minutes thank you chair members of the
committee and thanks to Alex obviously
for his work on the application to date
and for the report that you've got
before you today firstly this is
actually a really simple proposal the
applicants are fortunate enough to have
purchased this site with the Planning
Commission in place for the two houses
they have they were not involved in any
of the previous applications or the
appeals um and they are building those
houses currently and will want to live
in one of them um they're moving from a
nearby Village the applicants have these
horses at their current home and simply
wish to relocate them to live next to
them when they move they require that
stabling for the horses and we'll graze
them on that land and that is all this
application seeks to
achieve comments have been made around
possible commercial use and in response
to that I can tell you that's that's not
what the application proposes is not
always intended indeed members have made
comments this morning about access to
that facility in terms of large Vehicles
which just isn't practical that's not
what this is about there are a total of
three stable boxes within the building
the applicant currently has two horses
she rehomes horses wishes to continue to
be able to do that and we'll be simply
looking to potentially put a third horse
on there at some point in time time
there is absolutely no space for
commercial use to
occur the comments have been made around
when development of this site will stop
and you've heard mentions of salami
slicing as I mentioned the applicants
were not responsible for any of the
history of the site there was permission
to build the two houses these are being
constructed and they wish to stable
their horses on the land in the next to
the dwelling they'll be living in that's
it comment are made as to proximity of
the Stables to the churchard and burial
ground the document that you've seen
this morning has not been sent to me
I've had no comment no opportunity to
comment on the Heritage officer's
comments the application has been with
this Authority for over six months um
and we're presented with late comments
the night before a committee meeting
with an opportunity to respond that's my
only thing I can say on that the
applicants are also more than happy to
provide a waste management scheme
through a condition of any permission
granted that seems to be a normal
requirement for mids suffk when dealing
with stable applications we don't seem
to prepare them up front or have them
proposed up front and indeed there are
cases where it's not required at all
we're more than happy to provide
that this is not a proposal that gives
rise to landscape impacts it's tucked
close to but not directly up against the
roadside hedge and its scale is not such
it it stand out in longer views of the
site it is a simple but well-designed
traditional building traditional
materials for the storage and sorry for
the accommodations and storage
associated with the applicants own
horses the applicants have confirmed
that access will be through the approved
access to the housing the access that
you've questioned onto the corner of the
site will be closed up by h it's not a
pedestrian access as an error on the
plan
apologies the issue of flooding has been
raised despite the significant flood
flood events experienced in men recently
that part of the site did not flood the
lower elements where the hous are being
built absolutely did so that element
where the Stables are going was not
underwater and we have photographic
evidence of
that the the applicants are actually in
the process of clearing a further ditch
outside their site and desilting a road
drain that is clearly blocked up with
months and years of debris they don't
have to do that that but they're doing
that to help that situation in summary
your officer has fully considered all
the material considerations that are
engaged has confirmed the application
meets with both existing and emerging
policies is thereby hope that you will
support this proposal and able the
applicants to a to house their horses
horses sorry adjacent to their new home
thank you uh thank you uh do we have any
questions of Mr
Elvin um uh if there are no other
questions can I just ask um given that
it is so close to the
flood plane is the hard standing for the
parking uh
permeable oh absolutely we and you can
condition that we're more than happy
with that no problem at
all uh uh
councelor thank you um could you tell us
a little bit about
lighting um obviously it's quite a
sensitive area a churchard just wondered
what the stable lighting was proposed to
be absolutely we need to design
something I mean the conditions talk
about Wildlife sensitive lighting and
this is for the applicant's own horses
so it's not something we're expecting it
to be lit for the purposes of other
people to attend the site so it doesn't
need to be lit for Livery for example
where people would be coming and going
potentially so we'd be looking at
something lowkey probably on a on a
sensor so that as you move it would
light and we can control that um we just
need to design it at the
moment you thank you um any uh councilor
Davis uh thank you chair this may not be
an acceptable question but clearly Our
Heritage officer did suggest moving the
stable block through 90 degrees is that
obviously you haven't had a chance to
look at the detail but is what's your
initial
reaction well actually I can kind of see
the logic to it in terms of the the
physical relationship to the houses I
just think actually probably in Heritage
terms is going be more harmful it's
going to be bringing the building up the
side of the churchyard boundary
potentially um rather than sitting away
from from it um we haven't I I haven't
spoken to the applicants at all this was
a complete surprise to me this morning
um but swings and roundabouts I can see
Merit but I also can see some
harm thank you uh Council
ma yeah I I I guess it' be useful to ask
ask this question of the officers um
while the the agents here um in in
planning terms the um it's been
described as domestic not commercial by
by the agent now and um and not Livery
which presumably is commercial horek
keeping um is there any is there any
distinction to be drawn in planning
terms I mean c can we actually make
that can we constrain the
application in the way that's been
described or is is that just window
dressing syst be um bit I'm I'm fair
about it sorry is the query whether we
can condition and control it to be for
personal use only rather than anything
else
yeah yep so we've got a condition on
there at the moment it's about halfway
down and it's titled restriction on
development not to be used as commercial
delivery riding school or for other
business purposes it gives the option I
think Alex and I did discuss whether it
might be personal and that is an option
open to committee that it would be only
for these the the person living in the
house as Mr Alin mentioned but I think
that would not necessarily be reasonable
in this case because you've got the
village it could be somebody else in the
village would go there in the future if
it was sold for example but it would
still be only their personal horses for
their personal use but that is an option
yeah so so the what you're saying is
that condition is is as takes us as far
as we can other than if we start talking
about personal to the
applicant okay well we'll come back to
that
I would probably still say that would
still be personal use you are a person
and it's your horse and you were there
the question over the renting out bit is
is something we might need to explore
further by condition and really be
specific but the the critical thing is
it's not a business you've not got three
different people having their horses
there that you maybe look after and
there in and out you know more movement
it's
about the owner of the site or a person
keeping their horses there would have
the same impact um and of course we have
got to be aware of is it relevant and
necessary and related to planning I
think that to me steps a little bit
beyond what we might think is reasonable
if it's okay for one person to have
their horses there does it matter if
they live in the house next door or one
over the road or or in you know
potentially in the village or whatnot so
I think that me is I said I think Alex
and I had the conversation and did
consider it in quite a lot of detail so
I think we were content that that would
go as far as we thought would be
reasonable I think Mr isbel would like
to just because it's good to just to
clarify further I mean I think it's
important to distinguish between
ownership and
occupation um if members consider that
the occupation of this in association
with the adjacent dwelling is important
and that's often the case that's
important and that's members to debate
if cast your mind to the situation where
perhaps in future the house is sold
separately to this land what then will
be the relationship between the two uses
and you would want to anticipate that
for sure um but there are probably quite
a few questions in here which I'd
suggest we see how debate goes and then
come back to
those right uh uh councilor
hardingham yeah would there be any um
likelihood of a further uh The Next Step
being the construction of a
because this is something that we see
very often with um uh that follows on
from the construction of stables and and
and a bit of fencing that the the next
move is a man and the and the next one
is um is some lighting
um and um as a question for the case
officers would that be a separate
development also subject to further
planning yeah absolutely we often see
planning applications for manes so yet
would need consent and we'd have to
consider that on its merits at the time
um maybe the agent might want to come in
on that point about their future plans
but just bearing in mind that that is
subject to Future
application there there's absolutely no
intent to put Minaj in we simp this is
simply a relocation of her existing
hores situation of keeping rehomed
horses at her site a little way up the
road um to build bringing them next to a
house so I have no understanding of any
further development or proposals which
Parish Council will surely be pleased to
hear um of anything else going on after
this position being taken today thank
you um so um if there are no further
questions then we'll move to the ward
member councelor Andrew
Stringer thank thank you chair and and
thank you committee uh thank you for the
opportunity to speak just want to if I
may just uh draw a line under a few
things and and get a few things out in
the open
um it is I agree with the agent
wholeheartedly uh that it is it is not
acceptable to have a Heritage response
this late in the day uh to
which the parish would have liked to
have responded to that because actually
I think it's fundamentally flawed uh
because we're not able to contact the
officer in this time uh and and yeah
while the meeting's in session I don't
think it's yeah that document should
have been here at least 48 hours before
so we could have actually checked and
doubled checked what is going on CU this
application has been in the mix as we
can see from the photographs were taken
back in April when everything was in
full flour uh and all the leaves were on
the trees and the Sun was shining uh and
and things look a great deal different
today anyway back to what we have in
front of us um I I I don't think anyone
has a problem with people keeping horses
on this land uh in M uh there's been
horses on this land for many or part of
this land for many many years this land
does however have a really curious
history and a vital part of Mam's first
and second neighborhood plan the views
across this site have sought protection
from the original local Plan
1998 and further reinforced in the first
neighborhood plan in menum 2015 and
subsequently renewed last year in the
updated neighborhood plan so the
importance of the views across this site
have been known to this Authority since
1998 and protected from
then deeming a visually important open
space those have now gone pretty much
because of the new local planning
framework has has sought to you change
those but they've been brought into the
neighborhood plan back in 2015 and
renewed again last year so this this
view being sought protection is nothing
new it is absolutely vital and it's and
you can you can work out how vital it is
if you read the in inspector's decision
for the eight dwellings on this site the
inspector walked the
paths actually the paths that weren't
you didn't get the views
from in in the submission from the
officer which is very disappointing
because views are sought both ways there
are two bits of this site that are
historically incredibly important it's
the setting of that church rising up
from the churchard on that corner from
that corner and also from the footpath
that runs alongside of that and from the
footpath that goes along the front of
the church and the scheduled ancient
Monument which is the
moat which is why when we first saw an
application on this corner for stables
and the access originally was actually
coming out on that corner which we're
glad to see that's an amendment that the
access to this site is not going to be
vehicle access is not going to be around
the corner we're glad to see that
however the further erosion of that vist
along brockford road is the pivotal
Point yes it's behind a hedge so for
much of the year you won't see the
Stables but from now on you will see it
and I fundamentally disagree with that
Heritage offic a view well it's been the
View's been split already so we'll split
all of it it depends where you're
looking from regarding the
split and if you are looking from it
from the vistas that that appeal
inspector looked at when he was looking
whether to uphold the neighborhood plan
policies is absolutely vital and you
today haven't seen those Vistas in the
presentation and you haven't seen them
at this time of year which is really
disappointing anyway let's get past the
disappointments I've got a question for
the officers as well would the approval
of this application potentially create a
Brownfield
site first of all uh I I'm have I'm
disappointed that the report suggests
the application Accords with the made
and remade M neighbor plan neighborhood
plan from our perspective from the
parish perspective it it really doesn't
um it I say disappointed about the late
paper uh and we feel this application is
still despite the amendment with the
driveway contrary to the Views protected
in that neighborhood plan and uphold by
the appeal inspector in
so how yeah what do we what do we
suggest we've had a Heritage of was
already saying well you could reate the
building etc etc well yeah you could but
actually you could put the stable
somewhere else where it would then be
completely in accord with the
neighborhood
plan I I personally believe there is a
solution here I believe this is not the
solution and this particular solution is
not in accord with that neighborhood
plan I believe and the parish council
believes so uh yeah Where Do We Go From
Here U it's it's a difficult one and
it's it's up up for you to decide but
it's very difficult for you because you
haven't seen what that appeal inspector
saw and and what made him refuse the A
and that is absolutely pivotal and I'm
really you know disappointed that you
can't see that despite this being in the
system for over seven months
um I think that's all I needed to
say in terms of uh the protections and
and why we feel this is not in
accordance with the made and remade
neighborhood plan but happy to answer
any questions if there are any thank you
uh do we have any questions council
heading thank you um I can see Andrew
and I know that you are a passionate
supporter of um neighborhood plans but
there are any five um objections what do
you say to do you just say that people
are expecting you and the parish council
to fight their case and actually the
whole village cares about it deeply or
you just saying you know what what's
your answer to only five
objections that that's five people that
were minded enough to protect what is a
view and that's a view from a particular
corner I I wouldn't have cared if there
were none we have we have policies here
and we have previous decisions here that
have found the value in that if an
appeal inspector values that view after
walking it going actually I'll tell you
what no no no you cannot have those
eight despite the economic uplift I I
don't mind people having stables around
their houses it's not a huge economic
outlift uplift there's no Livery here
there's there's no economic uplift to
this this is someone's domestic pleasure
great I I really want them to be able to
do that but it needs to be balanced with
the harm it might create to the rest of
the community and what's written down in
policy before this plan was drawn up
everyone knew that view was
protected everyone knew that appeal
decision and
why
um if there aren't any other questions
can I I'd like to just ask a question
the appeal decision on the eight
referred to the view from the footpath
out the back of the church that goes
adjacent to the schedule ancient
monument that appeal decision I think
was in
2021 um was there any consideration to
adding that as an important view in the
updated neighborhood plan well it it is
it is where that arrow is pointing it's
not pointing I thought the issue was the
view from the foot path it is the view
both ways but but the arrow on the
neighborhood plan only goes from
brockford Road Corner yes but it doesn't
pres but the clue is in the name
visually important open space if you can
look one way you can look the other and
we can't put an arrow on the map that
points both ways can
we
could what I'm saying is on that map
there isn't a green arrow pointing along
the foot path up towards St Mary church
but but there is point Arrow 10 points
across a protected visually important
open space to the
footpath the footpath runs along there
it points to that footpath so it
presumes you can see the schedule
ancient monument and you can see back
from the scheduled ancient
monument and we believe on and and
actually this is where it's also a bit
disappointing because our documents
suggest that appeal decision in in the
listing in the committee P it said it
was on an adjacent site that appeal
decision is this site that's an
important thing to
note uh any further
questions thank you it's really for Alex
I'm probably just being a bit thick so
the two houses that have been given
permission that was on another appeal
and they're just just further up the
road so they don't get in the way of the
view is that is that
right
so um yeah the blue line is um yeah that
well outline outline was done at appeal
um you know we had to pick up the pieces
of that and do the reserve matters but
yeah um essentially that is in the area
the blue line and the um red line for
the eight is shown in your uh in your
table papers which um yes and my
apologies councelor Stringer it is to
confirm it is part of the um of the site
it would be um this this area here but
um yeah that's formally shown in your
table of
papers thank you uh so if there are no
uh further questions uh I will now open
this item Up For Debate anyone like to
make a contribution councelor mats thank
yeah I actually it's actually a question
really the the the the Heritage officer
found that there was
um lost it again now
um I must read it correctly um result
the harm was a very low level of less
than
substantial harm yes um is that is that
harm that requires any public
benefit uh yes in short so we've got to
follow paragraph 202 the second that we
identify any level of less than
substantial harm it has to be outweighed
by public benefit but we are looking at
what essentially is the lowest of the
low not just low very low so we
are the small amount um of harm so it
doesn't need to be balanced by public
benefits but those
benefits are only outweighing the small
level of harm so is that of um grains of
sand harm here benefit here balance that
we need to
undertake what do we think the public
benefit actually
is probably subjective isn't it is that
is that a subjective question are
you it's a question do the officers
think that there is a public benefit in
the application that's in front of
us well chairman um rather than try and
put words into somebody's mouth you have
the agent before you it's a question you
could ask
him um Mr Elvin would you like to say
what what what the public benefit is of
this application uh not really I haven't
had any opportunity to think about it
this was presented to me this morning
this is the whole problem with this as
as councilor string has pointed out this
is a fundamental response that
potentially changes the way you need to
balance your decision and neither the
officer or myself or the parish council
or the ward member have given it any
thought I was working this morning as Mr
Stringer can attribute to because I saw
him in the coffee shop opposite and I
haven't I still hadn't received this so
until I walked in this chamber I wasn't
aware that we were even talking about
any Heritage harm so I'm sorry I don't
know no well I I I I I mean I I'll
apologize for that for the because I
raised it at my chair's briefing and I
said that the um the out the appeal
decision referred to herit was the main
reason was for Heritage uh reasons as
why it was refused and I said well how
come our heritage officers haven't made
have chosen not to make a comment so I
asked the planning officers to go and
ask if the Heritage officers would make
a comment and and I've only I only saw
it this morning but um you're right
it's it's too late U because we need to
digest it but
anyway I I I fundamentally think it's
dangerous and I would I suspect that the
legal officer might VI on is to take a
decision on that without without any
correspondence or any opportunity to
respond I don't wish to put words into
people's mouths but the applicants are
going to be really really frustrated do
do de pray um about whether whether we
ought to allow um the applicant and the
Parish to respond to this response from
par sorry can I be heard
um yeah I mean I think Madam chair if I
may say so there's no there should be no
criticism of you for raising the point
at chair's briefing um it was I think if
you like the the fairness depended on
what was said because you you might have
had a comment a late comment saying we
have we really have nothing to say
counselors but I think there may be a
fair point that the it is a quite
detailed response it only refers to a
low level of of substantial harm but we
heard it said the the the um applicants
agent feels a bit AG grieved that he had
that he he ought he would like to have
had a better opportunity to consider it
with his client and I we're hearing I
think that the parish council have some
reservations and questions about the the
nature of it I
think um yeah I mean I think I I I read
it about the same I was aware of it at
the same time as as most people um at
the very least we need to consider yes
whether there would be an issue of
fairness either way with a decision made
on that basis
um like to take a bit of time out to
speak to colleagues if but the chief
planning officer may have something to
say to Mr isbel thank you chairman um
just listening to the debate and
discussion
um I think Mr Alin and his client would
clearly like to walk out this with a
decision that everyone can be confident
in I think Parish Council would like
that I think the board member would like
that um the question of how we get to
here with the comment from Heritage and
uh the question of um the appeal
decision and its relevance you know I
mean that question of mature reflection
I
accept now um there's clearly a question
about whether this building is
orientated in a way which members may
find acceptable or other otherwise and
leaving aside the question of whether
you think the Heritage uh impact is such
as it is perhaps there's value in um
members proceeding to debate this so
that we have clarity as officers as to
whether or not they are minded to accept
it or not um and uh if bearing in mind
that Mr Elvin has expressed concerns
about not having had access to these
comments um one could do various things
one option is to actually go and see
this for yourself
to walk the foot path to go and look at
it on the ground um and take stock of
both the important views and the overall
character of the uh open space so those
are options open to the committee but I
think to do that without actually having
some sense of whether you think this is
going in the right direction might be
doing the applicant a disservice in the
sense that as I understand it there are
concerns about the building as it
presently exists the Heritage officer
has made some comments about whether it
might be reorientated if if Mr Elvin is
client not willing to do that then
that's an answer in itself but that site
visit and that opportunity for
engagement would allow the breathing
space in which that conversation could
happen but if members say yeah we're not
worried by the particular orientation of
the building then there will be a little
pointing officers trying to pursue a
discussion about it so it would help
officers to have an instruction from
committee which kind of
informs what members are minded to do so
just thinking this through it would seem
valuable to proceed with the debate and
to get to that sort of conclusion
perhaps to allow for that to happen um
and to allow for some reflection on on
what's before you and for members to
indicate their their General wishes so
that officers can then you know review
this with the applicant and that's just
what occurs to me at this point in time
thank you uh Council
lawen the first is that the applicant in
my view should have had full knowledge
of what neighborhood plan entailed and
the views in that plan when considering
purchasing or building one of these
properties for their use
and I think inappropriate they should be
able to then come at a later stage and
override what is in that neighorhood
plan in an application for their
personal benefit neighborhood plans to
me are very
important small communities spend an
awful lot of time and
money um reviewing the plans producing
the plans and updating them and the
constant erosion of plans by people
moving into the village even if it's a
from a nearby one um should not in any
way be encouraged and I think by um
approving if we do are minded to approve
this um that we're just almost tearing
up local plans to a certain extent and I
totally disagree with a constant erosion
of um Heritage assets and Heritage views
um it's just just constant nibbling away
and the presentation we have here in my
view is well the view is split the
heritage is split anyway what the hell
um is totally wrong thank you thank you
um anybody else like to make comment
councelor
hardingham well I'd like to raise a
completely different point um which is
that I I knowe from the um from the
documents we've got that where new staes
are proposed applicants will need to
demonstrate that riding or other activi
can take place on their own land or on
other Land by legal agreement on a
long-term basis or on nearby defined
bridleways or byways um and while um
this particular fairly small field of of
about one hectare uh might well be
adequate for two or three elderly horses
to to to meander about on um if those
horses are then replaced by something
something else alog together they will
need exercise um there are no defined
Bridal ways or byways accessible
nearby just wanted to raise that
point uh councelor maton did I see your
hand yeah really I I'm just um you know
I'm just anxious that that whether
making a decis you know whether a
decision would be a risk um in in terms
of of the you know the unsatisfactory
consulty um submission the last minute
um you know if if we were using that as
part of a reasons for
refusal
um or even for approval despite it um
you know are we not you know taking a
risk which we could avoid by by actually
deferring possibly for a site visit and
and for for people to have a proper look
at the the heritage submission um you
know it's I don't feel very comfortable
about it personally but you know I think
legally the legally that is the the key
thing is it a risk to to take the
decision thank you um um yeah I
mean it's not at all uncommon for
consulties and officers to make late
almost last minute comments though it
would often be in the context where
they've already commented first and
there their responding further ISS it
depends on the circumstances I can't
mean coun I can't deny councelor mat may
have something to point that we this is
if you like if i' not very much mistaken
the first we've heard substantively from
our heritage colleagues on this
application is yes I think colleagues
are nodding I thought that was the case
um and it's something's being said which
the agent has only had at the last
minute and the parish council if I heard
correctly the parish council and the
ward member have concerns and disputes
with what is said said in the Heritage
comment um May I just ask Council
Stringer if I'm right about that yeah I
mean I've read very quickly as Ben's
read uh the response from Heritage OB I
I I think there's an issue with it in
terms of the language from where we're
coming from we we fundamentally disagree
with what the heritage offic is saying
but we've had we've had no time to
understand from What viewpoint that
Heritage officer is is making that he
may be making it from the Viewpoint of
of number 10 on the list of our views
then okay then that's his opinion he
might have been looking at it at the
wrong end as far as we're concerned but
we don't know that we can't find out
point Thank You counselor so um I um I
think that the chief planning officer is
right that it wouldn't be it would not
be legally wrong to proceed with a
discussion that gave an indication of uh
views as far as we can ascertain them on
on matters which he set out if if
members feel it's priv to do that but I
think I I would have reservations about
a resolution to approve or refuse being
made
today yeah thank you I mean I think you
raised a a good point actually with your
question councelor maon about the fact
that if there is any harm we we need to
see some public benefit and I'm a bit
concerned about this view from the
footpath that to my mind isn't the same
as an arrow pointing into the field from
the corner um views go both ways and why
not put the arrow both ways uh and I
think it is a bit disappointing that we
don't have any views from that foot path
because on looking at it just purely
from a plan it looks like that stable is
is not going to be intrusive if you're
on the foot path looking at the church
and the scheduled ancient Monument but I
don't know because I've never walked
along that foot path and we've got no
views of it so I'm I'm thinking maybe we
ought to go and have a look at it and
actually walk on that foot path and see
see what we think a stable in that
corner might look like um
and that would give a bit of breathing
space to actually then digest the
Heritage officers comments but I'll I'll
hear what other people got to say well I
I think you know my my respons is you
know that the the legal advice and the
chief planning officer's advice seems to
be that we could usefully carry on and
and and
debate but not take the decision and
then go and have a look which is unusual
I can't actually remember doing that
before but um if that's if that's best
advice then
then I'm what I'm trying to say is I
don't think I can make a decision until
I've seen the view from that foot path
because it looks it looks on the plan to
be fairly unobtrusive but we're hearing
from the locals that it will really
affect that view from the footpath so I
I don't know I
councelor um if I was was writing if
John was going to propose that we go and
see I don't think we could can um
discuss it until we've actually seen it
there's no point saying I think this
when we you know completely might do 180
turnaround and then surprise everyone
after we've actually looked at it so if
if John hasn't um proposed a site visit
then I'm happy to do that and councelor
Davis did you have your hand up as well
sorry I missed your hand waving uh thank
you chair yeah no I uh was going to make
the same point really I'm strong
supporter of local neighborhood plans um
and on this topic without being able to
actually see this uh valuable landscape
it's it's for me not possible to take a
decision so I would very willingly
second the
proposal to uh have a
visit uh so we now have a proposal and a
second for a site visit a a deferral in
order to do a site visit do we also want
to add in that there needs to be some
um I don't know what's the word inter
reputation of the Heritage officer
recent comments
um um Council waro has hand up did you
want to say something let's Council war
and then perhaps Mr Isbell can
explain uh yeah well I I think
I'm in favor of actually sort of a site
visit so we need to actually really look
at the impact of this I I also think
perhaps councelor hingham's comments
need to be um uh taken up as well
because perhaps we do need to look at
how this um links into Bridal ways
and and
other and other ways of exercising
horses or enjoying the facility of the
Stables there I it's that almost seems
to me a sort of little Gap in the
consultation as
well Lawrence did you want to chip in
before Mr
isbel thank you very much chair
yes I'm I'm quite intrigued I'd like to
uh see do a site visit but I'm just
curious within my own mind and this is
almost a self- question by doing a site
visit and looking at the scene ourselves
are we setting ourselves above what the
locals think of the value of that scene
is you know are we acting like little
tin Gods
again thank
you interesting point thank you uh coun
uh Mr isbel thank you chairman well have
I got that one no no if I can just take
that point no I don't think so I mean
this is a democratic process um one of
the thing my interest in your expressing
a view as to what you were minded to do
and accepting that you haven't seen the
land on the ground and and haven't seen
the relationship of things is you've
heard from Parish Council you know
there's a neighborhood plan policy
that's development plan section 386 of
the ACT says you follow the development
plan unless there's some other material
consideration um obviously Mr IR has
been put on the spot about the public
benefits question um that's for him
perhaps to answer and it is the right
test in relation to Heritage because not
only have you got the nppf to to to to
address but you have to follow the
statutory code and and ensure that you
um you know Safeguard Heritage assets
under the the statutory D duties that
you have but there is no harm in going
and looking I mean you're about to hear
another application in another uh Parish
um with a different
recommendation this is a democratic
process if it was simply down to
officers that that there is a question
of confidence in your decision making
which comes from going on site visit and
gaining information I personally feel
that if you went on that site visit and
said well thank you very much it's
lovely to see that but actually we're
going to follow the naal plan anyway the
purpose of that site visit would be a
little bit OTS so actually there is
value in expressing some sort of view as
to you know whether you think that's an
important point the applicant needs to
deal with because Mr Elin is unlikely to
recommend to his client to think about
the orientation of the building if
there's no steer to do that if you if
we're simply going to follow the a to
plan then I imagine making a decision
here and now would be the most
expeditious thing but taking in the
round going on a site visit is always a
sensible thing if you don't feel you can
make a decision on the information you
have before you so it's not a wasted
exercise even if by and large you think
you know what what you're going to see
but I think there is a value here
application's been in for a while we
don't want to prolong it but there is a
value here in being able to give
confidence to Mr Alvin which direction
we might be going because he might wish
to advise his client you know you need
to consider the size of this building
you need to consider its orientation and
and and that discussion can happen
whilst you're you know going on your
site visit and we know that the land and
the its character is important to the
community that's written in Spades in
the neighborhood plan um if that's
something that you think really is
something of great Focus for you maybe
this is an opportunity to express it can
I ask one last question councelor hardam
talked about various
requirements about access to uh byways
and other things perhaps he can help me
just remind me where that he drew that
from it's actually in this planning
document um I'm afraid this is just um
shut itself down again but
fine um right paragraph 34 page
22 of the
agenda so so chairman to conclude you've
you've got a um a proposal of aign visit
I I think there's value
in indicating some sort of uh whether
you're minded to to to to to go in in
favor of this or or might seek to to um
follow the neighborhood plan and um take
a view about its orientation or size
just so that officers can have that
conversation but I fully accept that's
just me as an officer expressing a
preference and if committee don't want
to do that they don't have to uh
councelor Hingham thank you can I just
say what I feel that the value of of the
site visit is clearly this is an
important view it's on the neighborhood
plan none of us want to go against the
neighborhood plan but surely we are then
looking at this important View and
thinking does this affect it or not no
one wants to go against the the the the
neighborhood plan we've got to sort of
think how is this affecting this
important surely that is the reason for
the site visit uh Council yeah I I think
you know reflect reflecting on Mr
isbell's advice and so on um you know
the the the the two issues not only the
view Etc and the her Heritage um but the
heritage is the first point at which uh
the the orientation of the building has
been raised I don't think we can you
know we need to give the officers an
opportunity to read the Heritage advice
and when you said about interpreting it
I think yeah digesting digesting it and
etc etc and I don't think there's any
benefit in trying to discuss any of this
uh
today Council
hardingham um well in in the first place
I would be inclined to agree with
councilors um uh Davis and Lawrence on
the Primacy of the um local plan um but
um as a separate um Point alog together
um this council is absolutely committed
to um improving um nature in the
district um 30 by3 um and uh increasing
biodiversity um in terms of public
benefit that might be derived from the
development um I would suggest that BNG
biodiversity net gain might be something
that could be considered if one were
minded to approve it um and and then the
question arises what is the condition of
the site at the moment what was the
condition of the site um six months or a
year ago when from the Google Street
View that I've looked at it was rather
tusky grass um of quite High um
biodiversity value um and we don't know
what the state of it is now um but I I
gather it might be considerably worse um
so I I think that's something that we
could think about um in terms of you
know ecological benefit thank you did
did I hear um did I see Council W or
not yeah I haven't quite got my thoughts
in order so I might ramble a bit more
than usual
um when I when I looked at this plan it
it seemed quite a sensible place to put
stables in relationship to the buildings
got those little
tow of the boot as it were of the the
building to put it on um but looking at
the neighborhood plan and the history of
the site and the the
impact of this development on that is um
is for me a sort of pivot around which
everything would would um could be
decided um this this and I'm not I can't
this late um appearance of the document
from the Heritage people um and there's
one line in it uh a
realignment of the building would remove
the harm entirely which would actually
sort of cancel out a lot of my
reservations and and this was alluded to
by counselor Stringer as well in that he
he mentioned that it will be possible to
sort
of uh reduce or possibly remove any
impact on this visual Space by a
realignment of the um the outbuildings
um it's I think it it it is very unfair
on on the the agent to sort
of ask him to sort of respond to this
document at this moment in time he's
he's only just got it and I think it's
perhaps wrong for us to really base our
decisions on what's being put in this
document because it will we getting
information which other people can't
it's it's not transparent anymore is it
it's it's really mudded the waters so I
think we do the the site visit
may give us an insight into what the
site looks like at this time of year I
did Google I did visit the site on
Google if you like and and
and and traveling along brockford Road
you wouldn't be aware of a visual open
space on the other side of the Hedge
because it was in the middle of the
summer and unless you ride in a horse
you won't be able to see Over the Hedge
roads apart from Through The Pedestrian
axis on the corner I I think it will be
of value to see it at this time of the
year when when that impact is there and
but the Vis it would give a breathing
space to allow the agent and the Paris
Council to sort of
respond to this document and and what
this document says in particular about
removing the Harmon tiling so that
that's my thoughts on the matter I think
we we could we could discuss this at
length
um
but at the moment my
my AR my way the way direction of travel
if you like in my thoughts is to support
of the neighborhood plan and protecting
the the um visually significant open
space because that's historically been
established um and we could have more
arguments about the level of harm of
these buildings that they're lowlevel
buildings and the for domestic use and
and and I think it you the social
benefits are quite important there the
well-being for keeping horses for the
the residents so um I think we need that
breathing space and the site visit would
probably give us the mechanism by which
we could get that breathing space and
then we could come to a decision that we
would be confident in thank you I I must
admit oh sorry I just wanted to I I'm
I'm not I I struggle with this
reorientation of the building bit
because I can't visualize exactly what
what what the Heritage officer thinks
would be better because from a purely
from a desktop view you're right that
that building looks like it's tucked
away in a in a corner that you can't
really see from the foot path that well
um so so maybe maybe um it's the size of
the D of the building that may have more
impact than than where it is really
because it it does have three stable SE
sections it's got a high roof maybe if
it was that bit smaller it would have
less impact or that would that would
remove the harm I don't know we we don't
know we haven't had a chance to digest
it so um I think um I'd be supporting a
site visit and and a breathing space to
give officers and um the agent and the
parish council a chance to reflect on
the the latest document we've had from
Heritage uh
councelor thank you I was just yes sort
of very similar really um would feel
really
uncomfortable getting any further with
it today and would really welcome being
able to go and see it and obviously want
to support um the neighborhood plan
fully but I just feel like we don't have
enough information and perhaps the
parish council and the the agent also uh
need to have opportunity so yeah I would
really really like to go and see it but
I just wanted to Echo councelor
Harding's point about BNG and the
importance of that if if we're looking
at sort of direction of travel and and
public benefit I just wanted to say
that's something perhaps that could be
considered sort of in this breathing
space so thank you so we have a proposal
and a seconder for a site visit do we
need any more details on what what that
um proposal should be before we go to a
vote or is it just that we're going to
vote for a site visit I mean I'm happy
to chair I mean the from the notes I'd
made in various things I had put defer
for a committee site visit and I suppose
the question in my mind is whether that
includes and to review the size and
sighting of the stable building with
regards to the Heritage Haron vi10 so
that we're not not taking a specific
Direction but we might review it in
light of that which seems what members
are seeking to my mind but I'm open to
whether that's does that seem okay with
the proposal and the second y so um if
if that's okay can we go for the
electronic vote
please
okay thank you members so I've amended
that vote um the application number dc23
00305 be deferred to enable site
inspection to be undertaken and to
review the application as detailed by
the area planning manager and the
application to return to
committee uh thank you so um that's now
in post in progress so Council Lawrence
you managed to log in brilliant thank
you
e
thank you members that's seven votes for
and one against therefore that's
carried we have a proposed date of
November the
22nd
okay I'll look at some dates and um send
some details some proposals but that
that is the the the date when we have a
penciled in provisional yeah um and I
thought it worked quite well um I yeah I
mean obviously we can't please everybody
but it did I thought it worked quite
well when we had the site visit and then
we came back in and determined the
application on the same day I thought
that worked quite well but you could get
a substitute yeah um so um thank you for
that we've um that's the end of item 7A
so I'm going to propose that we have a
uh Comfort break and I believe the
visitors are going to come in for the
second application so
um
uh thank you and welcome back um we now
go to our second case uh DC
23387 2 at hemingstone Fruit Farm Main
Road hemingstone and I invite the case
officer Nikita Mossman to introduce the
application to committee thank you thank
you chair and good morning members
this is application dc23
03872 at hemingstone Fruit Farm on Main
Road in hemingstone and the proposal is
for the erection of additional EG
business units building and Associated
works for background the most relevant
planning history includes a lawful
development certificate that was sought
in
201627 to established the use on the
site which was considered lawful and a
further application in
2019/2020 for the continued use of
storage and distribution with a
builder's yard and Associated offices
offices which was granted since the 2019
application some of the use has been
converted to smaller EG units through
permitted development but this was not
confirmed if it was lawful with an
application or lawful development
certificate this is the aerial map view
showing the site in its context with the
existing buildings to the North and the
residential dwellings
nearby
this is a wider view aerial map which
shows the rural nature of the site and
Main Road running through the
middle this is the site location plan
with the red line showing the site and
the blue line showing the land in the
applicant's
ownership this is the constraints map
which shows that there is a grade two
listed building to the north of the site
and um the existing buildings oh wait
sorry there's a greater list of
buildings to the north of the site and
east of the existing buildings that is
highlighted in yellow there is also a
risk of surface water flooding on the
east of the site which is shown by the
black lines it should also be noted that
the site is outside of any designated
settlement boundary and is therefore
considered to be in a Countryside
location here is the site layout showing
the existing parking and access to be
retained with the proposed parking the
business unit and the staff picnic
area
these are the proposed elevations with
the north elevation at the top the South
elevation below and the East and West
elevations at the bottom the proposed
materials comprise of powder coated
metal composite panels and trims for the
walls and roof and up upvc for the
windows and doors the proposed Eve Eaves
height is 3.2 M and the proposed Ridge
height is 4.4
M this is the proposed roof and floor
plan this shows that there are six units
proposed within the building and the
total floor area is 600 M squared The
Proposal also include solar panels on
the roof of the proposed
building moving on to site photos this
shows the existing buildings on the site
and this proposal has a similar design
to the single story building at the
front this shows the existing entrance
and car park to the site which is being
retained
this is a view of the site showing the
area where the proposed building would
be cited and the relationship it would
have to the existing
buildings this is another view of the
site from the northwest corner facing
west and this shows where the proposed
building would be
located this is a view standing in the
northwest corner facing
south here is the boundary vegetation
between the existing car park and the
proposed car
park this is the view from the access
facing north onto Main
Road and the view facing
south and this is the view of the access
to be retained and this shows the land
opposite the
site in conclusion the recommendation is
to refuse planning permission this is
due to the unsustainable location of the
proposed building and the lack of
strategic environmental or operational
justification for the building to be in
this location as required as part of
policy CS2 of the mids core strategy the
proposed building the proposed
development is brought forward on a
specul speculative basis with no
identified occupiers and whilst it is an
extension of an existing site it does
not represent an extension to an
existing business and the applicant has
fell to evidence a commercial need for
the proposed development this is
therefore contrary to policies CS2 E9
and E10 of the the development plan as
well as SBO 3 and spo5 of the emerging
joint local plan thank you uh thank you
uh do we have any questions from Members
councilor ma uh yeah I guess um just can
you confirm that the district has got a
a satisfactory amount of um employment
land allocated and not yet
developed that's fine um I think that
would be a difficult question given the
progress of our JP um we obviously had
allocations and they are still available
under the current development plan up
until the point at which we adopt part
one of the JP and then allocations will
be uh open again so there is that
potential um also the JP does allow for
um commercial sites within the A14
Corridor and this site is outside side
of that so it it doesn't fall into
either of those options um I that's not
strictly an answer but I hope that
clarifies a little
bit thank you uh any more
questions um
councilor thank you um can I just ask
there was I think it said that they
hadn't the Heritage comment was that
they hadn't had there hadn't been a full
Heritage impact assessment provided is
that correct yes that's correct they
identified a very low level of less and
substantial harm and we had to outweigh
it by public benefit um and we
considered that due to the amount of
employment that the site would bring
that it could be outweighed um due as
it's a very low level of less and
substantial harm so they hadn't had full
info but their sort of professional
opinion yes was that okay thank
you thank you uh so uh we now invite the
public speakers to address the committee
and we have uh Tina new from the parish
council uh if you'd like to press the
button on your microphone uh and I will
time you for 3 minutes thank
you uh Madam chair members thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to speak I'm
speaking today as the Parish Clerk to
hemingstone Parish Council a body of
members elected to represent the
residents of the parish the parish
council raised objections following a
parish council meeting held on the 10th
of October which was attended by a large
number of residents who all cited sign
significant concerns regarding this
application and its potential adverse
effects on themselves and other local
residents these concerns include the
lack of information regarding the
proposed on-site activities and the
current breaches plural in planning
conditions already on this site and the
enforcement action should further
breaches occur Additionally the parish
council expressed concerns over the
adverse impact of light noise and smell
pollution for this site does not align
with the Royal character of the
Parish furthermore the council
highlights that the proposed operating
hours would negatively impact the
residents particularly those in a parish
class as a hamlet the class E zoning
which includes Commercial Business and
service activities was discussed in
relation to the intended use of the site
the council believes that the
application seems to be speculative
lacking detailed justification or a
clear demonstration of need the parish
council emphasized the importance of
providing evidence of deliver ability
and interest in occupancy to ensure
certainty in pro project
delivery the impact on close neighbors
is underscored referencing past
experiences with with vehicles and
on-site issues including the burning of
waste light and noise
pollution the potential encroachment of
modern Industrial Development around the
charity Farmhouse is noted raising
concerns about disrupting the
appreciation of the design designated
Heritage asset within its historical
function within an agricultural
setting the council also expresses
concerns about the proposed
development's impact on light pollution
noise pollution and its positive
potential negative effects on wildlife
and surrounding immediate neighbors the
council is concerned the development
will impact the fragile ecosystem and
the serenity of the
countryside the potential increase in
traffic particularly fast moving and
high volume traffic on country roads
created by the site is highlighted as
another major concern
putting additional pressure on the
already poor condition of rural roads
and
amenities in conclusion the parish
council would strongly ask the committee
to object to the application due to its
impact on residents amenities including
the noise Lighting hours of operation
vehicle movement and adverse impact on a
Heritage
asset thank you um do we have any
questions of the parish council
Representative no thank you very much
much um we now have an objector Dave
Penny um if you would like to press the
microphone and you've got oh well you
just have to wait for my timer to get
off because um miss new wasn't as long
as the three
minutes I want to give you your full
three minutes so right um anytime you
want to start I'll start the timer thank
you thank thank you madam chairman I
live approximately 250 m to the south of
the site which was not included on the
map there
um I've been it's been it was suggested
by several of other of the objectiv that
I took the full three
minutes um it's important to include
some background
information the level of activity and
noise is already completely out of
character with this rural area and we
can't see that any further increase in
activity can be sustainable hemingstone
Fruit Farm has had no connection with
fruit or farming since it was sold in
2019 it has been the site of CNL
construction who operate tarmac and
digging gangs overhead and underground
cabling operations and planning and
design of installation of traffic
management it's a large scale operation
this has been somewhat of a shock to our
small rural Hamlet as the number and
amount of noise of vehicle Vehicles
which are usually drop sided flatbed
trucks with Digger trailers attached and
we Now understand that there are 200
workers who who use this site um with
the subsequent loading and un
unloading prior to that they that that
there were Orchards and no more than
half a dozen permanent
workers according to the uh emerging
joint local plan um it would this
development would not favor local
development as it's more than 2 km
outside the A14 a140
Corridor um the s's approximately 2.75
from the nearest point of the 18 and 3.5
km from the a140 as the crow flies and
further by Road the most direct would be
via A Quiet
Lane further there is absolutely no need
for the expansion of activities at this
location there are currently 14
currently available at clayon court of
various sizes um admittedly some some
are slightly larger than the
proposed um this site is right on the
814 uh there's one available at spren
spon and also one at Hadley Road and
Hanford
cut um all these are in addition to an
unknown quantity of units that are
available to let right now at a AUM
which is between hemingstone and
epwi um I didn't even get as far as
looking at what was currently available
at Needum and Stow Market at the
weekend um the the applicant kindly
attended a residence meeting meeting
following repeated
invitations uh which was great but when
asked about the need he said that there
had been loads of interest and repeated
that but without any substantive
evidence when we continued to push him
he did said he did recall that someone
had wanted to store and distribute
candles from there he was completely
unable to say where this or or other
users uh would be traveling from or why
it was needed to be in hemingstone
um no Johnny almost uh provided
information about 200 people work from
the site I'm aware that the owner and
one other applicant actually live in the
village the other 198 therefore travel
predominantly I believe from ipswitch as
their vehicles are often seen on the
drives um there are a couple of
companies can finish your okay um with
your final
sentence uh we're concerned how how
noise travels is dependent on various
aspects such as screening and wind
direction for example the properties
directly to the east of the site are
screen to an ex stent by the existing
structures development to the south and
east of the recreational area in my view
could not do anything other than create
noise and disturbance especially to
charity Farm housing thank you um do we
have any questions of Dave
Penny uh councelor
Elken thank you chair um I get for for
Mr Penny and uh the parish as well I
know we can't take existing
enforcement situations into any sort of
consideration but without getting into
that you you both mentioned sort of
noise pollution light pollution I just
wondered if there was anything you
wanted to um add about that yes M may
may I
answer do
answer
um yeah um J there is there is currently
a live enforcement case concerning hours
of operation um the site has been
operating out of hours admittedly in the
last couple of months surprisingly
they've been a lot
better um there are also two other
potential Enforcement cases there's an
area to the
north uh Northeast of the site which is
been uh is now has become hardstanding
since the site was taken over in
2019 and an uh an ambulance support
service operates out of there uh
planning enforcement have invited them
to submit a retrospective planning
application as it as it's running as
this as the hard standing was put in
without planning uh planning enforcement
have also also asked them to put in a
retrospective planning application from
for an area to the south east of the
site which doesn't appear on the map sub
subsequently to those photos taken it
has now become a storage area so
planning enforcement are asking for
retrospective one there thank
you um any further
questions uh so we will move to uh we
don't have a supporter uh we do have the
agent uh Nick Barber so if you would
like to uh press the button on the mic
and you'll have you three minutes thank
you thank you madam chair um firstly um
as as has been alluded to existing
enforcement action has no bearing on
this application it has to be put
completely to one side um we are
currently putting together applications
as requested by the enforcement officer
we are dealing with it um and as Mr
Penny himself just accepted things have
been
improving so um the application before
you um a couple of years ago as um
Nikita mentioned the existing use was
adapted to make some smaller business
units really quite small um for business
starters that were working in garages at
their own Residential Properties and the
like
um when they were marketed there was
indeed an awful lot of interest in them
my clients aren't estate agents they're
not commercial developers so they didn't
think for one minute to um take details
of everybody that was interested the um
the type of business that are interested
are the ones one two people who suddenly
find themselves working in their garage
and needing extra space they're not the
kind of businesses who plan 2 three
years in advance to be able to say when
you get this through planning and it's
built in three years time yes we'd
really be interested in a small unit
small businesses are far too fluid for
that so um moving on WE carried out a
preapp application um with the Council
planning officers were wholly supportive
of The
Proposal um we then moved on to develop
the scheme and put in the planning
application um there are no objections
to this from your Economic Development
who accept the need otherwise they would
have
objected um your ecology officers
equally supportive because we are
enhancing the site um the area in ke
referred to as a picnic area is a
wildlife area with Swale there is
improved tree planting there are back
boxes and the like included in the
application as provided for by the
ecology
report highways no issues with regard to
traffic at all on the road
Network um no increase of um potential
highways risk fire service equally happy
and supportive and environmental health
now this is perhaps of particular
interest because the proposed use is
Class E which has defined by um planning
use classes is and I quote suitable for
use in a residential area so the
government has already decided that this
use is suitable for this area it will
not by definition create issues of light
pollution
noise um odors smells or the like so
quite frankly the objections with regard
to noise um and and Al like are are you
um almost finished if you could wrap up
with your final sentence please okay
absolutely
um so where are we yes there's the
objections that have been made um are
based on uh previous issues at the site
which are being addressed um and they
are based on conjecture and
misinterpretation of information within
the application documents including the
um belief in the village that the
application is for 247 use which it is
demonstrably not thank you thank you um
are there any questions of the agent uh
councilor
El thank you um you mentioned that the
new proposed units would be Class E I
think is that the same as the existing
units on site um the existing use is for
Builder yard and B8 I believe but the
smaller units were created in what was I
get confused now since they've changed I
think it was B2 um from B8 which was
permitted development B2 is effectively
the same as Class E I think I've got
those right the way around yeah so it is
it is the same use as those small units
um which were created recently
yes thank you um are there any further
questions
um I i' just like to ask a question of
my own um you you say you're currently
in discussion with um uh planning
offices about some other applications um
at the site yes um because of the uh
issues that have been raised earlier um
is there any consideration of uh some
sort of U master plan um of what you're
you know of of your vision for the site
of the future because that would be
really helpful for us I know we can't
take speculative applications into um
consideration for cumulative impacts but
if there are more applications
forthcoming had you considered like
putting them all in as a sort of Master
Plan it's it's not my understanding um
from my discussions that there is any um
intention to expand further um what I
was asked to do was look and see um how
I thought the site could be developed
for for this this SC SC of of unit I've
not had any further discussions at all
so you know my my brief started with
with looking at the whole
site um which as you've seen from the
plans is is quite extensive the blue
line um and saying you know analyzing
that the strengths weaknesses threats of
the whole site and saying what can we do
where can it be best positioned and how
you know how will it fit in with all the
other requirements like highways ecology
and and everything else and where would
where would give the best um solution
for everybody um I've no idea the the
other issues at enforcement were um I
believe issues before I got involved um
yeah I I I haven't got any so so the the
current the applications that that are
currently in discussion with planning
officers there to sort of
regularize um the the issues that have
been raised by enforcement absolutely
yeah there was a meeting with
enforcement on site um and it was
suggested how they were dealt with um
and that's what we're progressing thank
you um any further
questions um okay so we'll now move on
to the ward member uh councelor John
Whitehead thank you uh thank you chair
and good morning members I'm rather
surprised this application has actually
come to committee the parish council
only request that be brought to
committee should the officers be minded
to approve it and the parish comments
indicate a clear hostility to this
development the officer's report also
indicates that 13 online comments were
received 13 objecting and none in
support in fact the only support for the
application detailed in the report comes
from our economic development team who
do set out an economic case for the
development now given the existing
business units and offices my first
thoughts were this application seemed
logical expansion on the site I then
attended a parish meeting and here I'm
talking about a good turnout of local
residents from a small Hamlet rather
than just say a few Parish counselors
and the strength of local opinion
against this application became
abundantly
clear now almost all of my past
experience addressing planning
committees as award member has been to
do my very best to represent my
resident's objections to an officer's
recommendation for approval
members you all know that's an uphill
task and a big ask but with this
particular application that task is much
easier because I can let the officers
report do the talking so we read that
the site is in a Countryside
location the proposed buildings are on
arable land the site is located outside
the settlement boundary and is not along
the Strategic transport
corridors it's not the expansion an
existing business but rather speculative
development with now identified
occupiers the requirement to evidence a
local Lo locational need has not been
met so I don't feel I need to expand
further I think the officer's report in
paragraphs 11.1 to 11.6 clearly
articulate the reasons for refusal in a
better way than I could ever paraphrase
them so I'd like to close by saying that
I do understand the reason why the
applicant has brought this application
forward he explained at the parish
meeting which I attended how the
development in the income from it
generate would form part of his
retirement planning you know that
strikes me as a genuine and Noble reason
however members as a planning committee
you're here to judge the application
before you strictly on planning grounds
only and on that basis I for one would
be extremely surprised if you went
against the officer's recommendations
thank you thank you uh thank you uh do
we have any questions of council whitee
heads no okay so I will now open the
item Up For Debate um anyone like to
make a contribution councelor heading um
I think it's quite a clear-cut case and
I'm and I'm quite um happy with um the
the officer's recommendation and hearing
from the public and the um Parish
Council and the ward member and I'm
happy to propose that we go along with
the officer's recommendation for refusal
uh thank you do we have a second uh for
Council hingham's proposal thank you
Council Lawrence did you want to make
any comments at this
time anyone else want to um say anything
about this um proposal we've now
got uh councelor ma are you itching to
say anything no probably
not look like you no I I no really I I
just I just kind of find feel the need
to to you know on understand the use
classes and you know what use class is
permitted that's given rise to a level
of noise that's that's we've heard from
the objector
um and that presumably noise is part and
parcel of the um of the various
Enforcement cases um I just just
wondered um right we understand the new
E E Class suitable residential areas um
and you know what what's an acceptable
level of noise really um and what's
unacceptable in in the existing use of
the next door building which is I think
we heard B8 or was B2 mentioned as well
at some point um help us with any of
that at all just improve my
understanding I mean I'm not what's
what's there at the minute n you might
have to remind
me so there's a there was a ba8 they got
permission for a B8 continued use on the
site and then it was converted um under
kind of permitted development change of
use um to a B1 I think which is now
EG an EG is
your action on noise grounds already
yeah I mean there is the yes EG has been
found to be appropriate in a residential
area so it could it's office uses um
things one might do at home in the
garage as has been referenced they might
be slightly noisy but not so much as to
give a nuisance I think the the
separation Point might be the fact that
you can then become a noise Nuance
depending on the scale and volume and
time of those things now I haven't seen
any of that so I couldn't comment and
obviously that's the subject of our
enforcement investigation so we do have
to tread fairly carefully in separating
the two issues here today
but the concern from us or I think we
haven't got a concern we have spoken to
our environmental health colleagues it
is eg use and we could restrict it to
that so in terms of a refusal on noise
or nuisance grounds I don't think we're
suggesting that this time unless you've
got particular concerns beond that no
that's that's that's helpful thank you I
I I'm certainly support the office's
recommendation thank you anyone else
wish to um make a
comment on this application councelor
War
boys thank you chair yes um I think I am
I am sympathetic with with many of the
um argues put forward by the agent in
particular the need for small scale
industrial units um and the design of
the building with with phot Vol T cells
EV charging points you know it it it has
a lot of potential I think however I
also agree very much with the planning
officer's comments that this is the
wrong wrong place for this kind of
development it's the extension of a a
former fruit packing site which is now
uh a
commercial industrial
unit uh and although the
comments and the from well the planning
the the outstanding planning
enforcement um situation and the the
comments from the parish council show
the difficulties of operating this kind
of um industrial site
in on the outskirts of a small rural
Hamlet this is this is very much an open
Countryside around it um so although
it's the the right kind of building and
perhaps it does serve a a contribution
to the economic space I think this is
very much the the wrong wrong space we
have we have got plans for uh along the
a140 corridor and the A14 Corridor for
Planned um industrial employment spaces
which I think we we should we should
stick to at this point so so I'm in
support of the planing officer's
recommendations uh thank you uh anyone
else wish to um say anything um I I um
I'll I'll just say my thoughts uh I do
think that some thought has gone into
this application there is a sort of
biodiverse um bit of uh Greenery by the
picnic area that the design of the
building looks okay it's got solar
panels on I think the um applicant has
has done some homework there so um I'd
like to you know think that that's all
very well but this clearly is a site in
the countryside and it's got um a lot of
Van when you look at the Google um
street view picture uh it looks like
it's sort of overflowing with white Vans
and they've all got go along those
narrow lanes and that's the existing
built um commercial development and just
because there's already commercial
development should we really be
intensifying that traffic on the rural
roads when as as was pointed out by the
obor
there are there are several small
business units available um in more
sustainable locations and and ideally
we'd like those those small businesses
to take those up rather than build some
new ones in this rural location so uh I
would be supporting the proposal um um
uh because it isn't really a sustainable
location and just because we've already
got industrial activity there doesn't
make it right to put anymore um so does
anyone else wish to say anything so we
have a a proposal and a seconder um and
we've got the proposal as it is in our
papers um that you've got the reasons
for refusal um so are we happy to
proceed with the electronic vote um
thank you thank you chair members that
vote is now in
progress
e
thank you members that's eight votes for
refusal chair that's carried thank you
uh thank you so um that we have no
further um items on our agenda um so
item number eight uh is um site
inspections uh we have now got a site
inspection request um from the previous
application so uh the officers will be
uh arranging that in due course um and
hopefully sorting out a a convenient
date um um and there are no other um
request for site
inspections um so I can now formally
close the meeting at
12:00
um